la lista de renuncias crece en el
gobierno de boris johnson mientras que
los ministros de salud y finanzas
dejaron sus puestos más miembros de su
equipo se unen a las dimisiones se trata
de un nuevo golpe para un primer
ministro que ha tenido que lidiar con
varios escándalos en 2020 johnson y su
esposa renovaron su apartamento oficial
disponían de 35 mil dólares de dinero
público pero la obra costó más de 130
mil dólares según 'the guardian' más
allá del precio el origen de los fondos
fue el objeto de la controversia el
partido conservador recibió 62 mil
dólares de un miembro del partido en la
cámara de los lores para pagar las
facturas lo que llevó a acusaciones de
corrupción contra el premier el
escándalo del partido gates persigue a
johnson desde noviembre de 2000 21 el y
miembros de su gobierno están acusados
de haber celebrado más de una docena de
fiestas durante el confinamiento por la
crisis de kobe 19 la indignación
desatada por esas revelaciones sometió
al primer ministro a un voto de
confianza
el 59% de los diputados conservadores
apoyaron al líder de su partido un
resultado suficiente para salvarle de la
destitución a lo largo del mandato de
boris johnson varios diputados de su
partido se han visto envueltos en
escándalos sexuales el último implica a
crist pincher ex responsable de la
disciplina del partido conservador
acusado de agresión sexual pero el
escándalo empañó al gobierno cuando
surgieron a transacciones más antiguas
contra pincher de las que don instruido
negó tener conocimiento antes de
nombrarlo pero que johnson si conocía el
premier pidió disculpas y admitió que
estaba al tanto de las denuncias pero
dijo que las olvido para muchos
británicos y para los funcionarios que
siguen renunciando este último escándalo
fue la gota que colmó el vaso